Add of these leaders and actually look at what they believe and what they
believe.
Some of them is extremely disturbing,
especially when it comes to Jews.
So I write this column and I'm like pilloried for it by the left,
one of the leaders of the women's march,
this woman Bob Bland,
wrote this letter to the New York Times where she calls me,
um,
who was amazing.
I want to find what it was.
Oh,
she calls me an apologist for the status quo,
racist ideology and the white nationalist patriarchy because you responded to
someone because I said
is a man who called Judaism,
who calls juice termites,
who calls Judaism a gutter religion,
who says that we should burn in ovens.
And who by the way,
is a misogynist homophobe also the leaders of the women's March or associating
with this guy and had the nation of Islam security protecting them.
I mean,
this is like the most sort of retrograde hate group and yet for calling them
out,
I was called all of these things.
Now that's floors.
It's a deep question.
I think that part of it is the fact that in intersectional leftwing politics,
Jews have been whitewashed.
Jews are viewed as sort of the white privileged power and part of the white
patriarchy and less they genuflect and say,
actually,
no,
we,
you know,
we uh,
pour our privilege and all of the other things that you're supposed to say.
And there's a blindness to the fact.
Right?
And there's a blindness to the fact that first of all,
not all Jews are white.
Half of the Jews in the state of Israel,
for example,
are Arab and from Arab countries that they were kicked out of a 1948.
I mean,
the idea that Jews are white is this canard.
Although I'm an Ashkenazi Jew,
I'm,
my family is from eastern Europe.
I have white skin,
but I don't think of,
and I have white privilege,
but I don't think of myself as white person.
I think of myself as a Jew first and foremost.
So it's a complicated identity.
But I think that it's sort of a,
it's whitewashed by these people.
And I think that antisemitism just isn't taken seriously and doesn't rate
because people perceive Jews as having privilege and power in this country,
which largely they do.
But the fact is is that the actual statistics show that more hate crimes were
committed against Jews in the past year.
Then any other minority group,
the FBI's like sounding the alarm every other day in crown heights and in other
parts of Brooklyn,
random Jews who looked Jewish,
right,
who are Hasidic Jews are just beaten up for being Jewish.
And yet everyone's ignoring that because they're the imperfect victim.
Well,
they're also very isolated.
They're very,
they,
they're,
they have their own tribe.
They stick with them,
they look different,
they dress different.
Sure.
But imagine if any other minority groups,
someone,
I mean,
we're outraged when we see at least I am.
And you are,
when we see a police officer assaulting someone,
you know what I'm saying,
is a young black person,
they don't make a big deal
to go into the public about it.
They keep it almost insulated inside their environment and their,
their community.
There's also,
what I was going to say is they,
these people that are,
that you,
you do hear saying antisemitic things.
They're equating American Jews living in America with the policies of Israel and
what Israel is doing with Palestine and that somehow if you're an American Jew,
even if you're not even political,
you're somehow or another complicit with atrocities that are going on between
the Jewish people and the Palestinians.
Right?
Conflict.
Any kind of conflict,
and this makes it,
it reinforces their idea about you being apart of this.
Right,
but they group,
yes,
but they also straw man it and say criticism of Israel is an antisemitic.
Yes.
No one's saying the criticism isn't of Israel's antisemetic.
I criticize Israel all the time,
but there's an obsession on the state of Israel.
Like if you were an alien that landed from outer space,
you would think that the greatest oppressor in the world is this tiny state
that's the size of New Jersey.
These people say nothing about the Gen ed generally about the genocide of Weger
Muslims in China.
They say nothing about any number of even aware that,
oh,
there's a genocide going on,
carried out by the government of China against Weger Muslims.
They're literally being put into concentration camps.
This is literally a first I've heard of this.
So Weger is spelled you I.
G.
H.
U.
R,
whereas a,
what is a good thing to read about the New York Times we've reported on it.
It's a,
it's an enormous story and it's like the fact that that's getting no,
that you don't know about it.
Yeah.
And that people obsessively talk about the state of Israel is,
if it's the,
and by the way,
the state of Israel does lots of things wrong,
but the idea that it's among the worst human rights tragedies of our time.
Are you kidding me?
It's insanity.
Okay.
I don't know the reality of what is going on in Gaza.
I don't know what is happening with Israel and Palestine.
I don't know what we're going to be the person that talks about this,
but what I do,
what I do know from people that have gone there,
like Abby Martin who came back with some pretty horrific stories,
I think there's a lot of terrible shit going on.
There's a lot of awful violence and there's a lot of despair on the side of the
Palestinians and I don't,
I don't know who's to blame for that,
but many people blame the Israelis.
They blame the Israelis for treating the Palestinians as if they're in this one
area of the world is essentially a large prison.
Well,
lots to say about this,
but I think one of the main problems that we have in the way that Israel is
covered is that if you have a camera lens and you're only looking at a tiny
piece of land,
right?
You're only looking at Israel proper,
the West Bank and Gaza,
right?
Israel to some extent is the Goliath in that situation.
But if you zoom out your camera just a little,
you see that Israel is literally surrounded on all sides by genocidal regimes,
like in the form of Hamas in Gaza,
whose charter blames the Jews for fomenting the French revolutions,
the Russian revolutions,
both world wars and says that it wants to kill all the Jews.
That's what,
that's the government of Gaza right now.
I spoke to a mother,
um,
who fled Gaza recently.
Okay.
And her family's house was just destroyed.
Who is it destroyed by?
Hamas,
not Israel.
You never hear those stories.
So I'm just saying it is a very complicated
politics,
but when you see people obsessive really focusing on this one state and the
crimes of this one state to the exclusion of actual dictatorships in the world
who are killing their own people,
you have to be suspicious of that.
You do have to be suspicious and you do have to be aware of their position in
the world surrounded by Arab states.
You,
you do have to realize that they are,
you know,
they're,
they're alone out there.
You also,
I do wonder what is the motivation for so many people focusing on Jews?
What is it like?
What do you think it is as a Jewish person?
What do you think the motivation for this kind of racism and discrimination
against Jews and why is it tolerated?
Why?
Why can someone like Louis Farrakhan tweet that Jews are termites and his
Twitter account stays up?
Well,
it's the oldest hatred in the world,
right?
A lot of it sound what it is.
No,
no,
no.
You're asking me why is it still with us?
It's like the mystery of history.
Like that is,
that is deep.
I mean that is something that goes back to the new testament.
The Jews were blamed in the book of John and mark.
I mean,
we could go to Matthew for the death of Jesus.
Their role in that story,
at least according to some of the books,
is that they convinced the most powerful empire at the time,
the Roman Empire in the form of the Governor of Judea,
Pontus pilot to kill the son of God.
That becomes sort of a template for the antisemetic conspiracy theory.
There's,
there's a confusion about what antisemitism is,
right?
It's not just a hate.
It's not just like this hate of a group racist perceived themselves as punching
down against a group that's lesser antisemites perceive themselves as punching
up against the secret cabal of Wiley operators who secretly control the levers
of power.
That is the canard of antisemitism.
And that begins with this group that's able somehow to get the Roman Empire to
kill Jesus.
Now,
the Catholic Church disavows this in 1965,
uh,
which was,
you know,
an enormous historical event.
But that template is still there and you see it play out right in who?
Who led us into the war in Iraq.
Ah,
it was the Jews of the bush.
You can see it play itself out all over the place.
And right now in the demonology of current contemporary antisemitism,
Israel has sort of been made into the Jew among the nations.
You're not allowed to say anymore.
It's like the old school antisemitism,
right?
Like I grew up in a place where there were some country clubs where Jews
couldn't go into them.
That frankly,
that's not dangerous.
What's dangerous is the kind of antisemitism that says,
you know,
this one state in the world of all of the almost 200 states,
that's the one that doesn't have the right to exist.
That's the one that should be dismantled.
That's actually dangerous to Jewish lives right now.
It is.
Um,
it's an unusual group in that it is both a religion and a tribe.
Yes.
It makes us very hard to understand in the contemporary landscape because we are
not just a religion.
There's nothing else like it.
Cause most Jews that I know do not practice Judaism.
Right.
And yet they,
yes,
because we were a people hood before we were a religion.
Religion is a very contemporary,
modern thing that Jews are sort of slotted into and it makes us easier to
understand.
But then are are sort of national identity or peoplehood.
Our tribalism is left out and that's an essential part of who the Jews are.
My friend Ari Shaffir,
who's a fantastic stand up comedian.
He's a rabid atheists,
but he's also very Jewish and he has a new hour that he's working on right now
that he's gonna film called Jew.
Really?
I want to see it.
Yeah,
but he's,
you know,
he's a perfect example,
but that's all tribe.
It's not just a religion,
but it's also because the Jewish religion itself,
the emphasis,
the emphasis is not on what you believe the emphasis is on deeds.
It almost doesn't matter what you believe.
It matters that you follow Hallah,
Huh?
Which is Jewish law and matters your deeds.
It matters all these things.
So it's possible to be a good Jew and not really think about God that much,
which is very strange.
I understand.
To Christian ears or you go full Ben Shapiro or he's both a good Jew and very
much like follows the whole deal.
We were thought as little deal the whole deal.
Um,
why do you said,
I think,
sorry,
can I say one more please,
please.
I just find it like kind of astonishing the blindness to this because imagine a
leader of the women's March said something like,
you know,
I think Louis Ck is the greatest comedian of all time,
even though I disavow x,
y,
and z thing that he did.
How fast till that person was kicked out of the leadership of the women's March,
it would be like minutes,
hours.
Yes.
I think there's certain things that get people outraged and other much worse
things that do not.
And I'm fascinated by why that is.
Do you think that if it was a white person that had this opinion about the Jews
that it would be more scrutinized?
I think that it is much easier to antisemitism when it comes in the form of
Richard Spencer.
Yes.
Because then there's liberal consensus right.
About him.
He's bad.
You have a green light to criticize.
Yeah.
It's very,
it is much harder when,
when an ant.
Exactly.
It's much harder when someone like Ilhan Omar,
the new freshman senator,
uh,
sorry,
not senator,
the new freshman congresswoman from Minnesota who's like this incredible
American dream story comes here at 12 years old,
refugee from Somalia,
wears a hijab,
is a mother,
is the first woman of color representing Minnesota.
Like obviously I want to cheer her.
That's my reaction to her.
And yet she has this tweet that she refused to apologize is four where she says,
Israel has hypnotize the world.
May Allah awaken the world to the evil doings of Israel.
I'm sorry,
that's a classically antisemetic trope.
Even if she said it unwittingly,
and by this point she should have known she should educate herself.
So it's very,
it's much harder to criticize that,
but it's,
it's an untenable position to say that you can't criticize someone for their
ideas because of their identity.
Like a road to nowhere.
That is a very vague thing to say.
You should be incredibly specific.
Have you want to say it's evil.
You should say what's evil and then open that up to some sort of a discussion or
debate,
but as,
but as scribing,
supernatural evil powers to a state is very much recalling classic antisemetic
canards right.
So that,
I really wrote a piece about this today.
Trying to like explain that to people because she went on CNN saying,
I don't know how Jewish Americans could be offended by this,
which I think is incredible.
What do you think if,
I mean,
if you want to be objective as step outside of your Jewish identity,
what do you think is wrong with how Israel is dealing with the Palestinian
situation?
Because this is the big criticism of Israel.
The only criticism really that's the big one.
The big one is Gaza and Palestine.
So what do you think they're doing wrong?
Palestine meaning the West Bank?
Yes.
Well,
I would say what the untenable position that they're in is that they are
occupying another people.
That is what is going on in the West Bank.
And I've been there many times,
met with many Palestinians.
I've really educated myself on this.
The problem is is that,
and by the way,
it's not all a Palestine.
There's the Sre,
all the Westbank,
there's areas a,
B,
and c.
It's a really Glick.
We'd have to pull up a map.
It's a pretty complicated thing.
There are places where it's much more autonomous and the PA's in charge and it,
it really varies depending on the area,
so the big criticism right is that they're occupying and other people and that
is corrosive to the state of Israel sort of morally like to to occupying other
people.
On the other hand,
what happens if they pull out of the West Bank tomorrow?
Right?
I'm for a two state solution ultimately ending the occupation,
but if I'm real,
I have to be honest about what that would look like.
What would it look like in Gaza is that now you have a terrorist statelet right
at the border which is ruled by Hamas.
It is quite likely that that very same thing could happen in the West Bank.
Now let's say actually we actually should pull up the map.
Let's,
let's say Israel does that then like the whole of Israel proper is something
like we have to looks two miles wide.
We actually,
yeah,
we should look at the,
the distance between like tool Carrum where like the end of the West Bank and
Natanya or Tel Aviv and you see how small that is.
I mean it's hard to even conceive of it if you were in charge of protecting the
security of the people who live in places,
which by the way,
10 years ago when in the year after high school when I was living there,
there were suicide bombings blowing up in cafes around the corner from where I
lived.
Or You gonna subject those people to that risk.
I mean that's the,
that's the actual question facing the government of Israel,
which by the way,
I'm extremely critical of,
and if I lived in Israel,
I'd be voting,
you know,
center left in Israel for sure.
But that is what they're facing.
And then if you zoom out and you pull up a map of all of the countries around
it,
okay.
I just want like,
look,
sorry.
No,
it's okay.
Actually the one you were on was good because it showed if you zoomed out,
it had everything.
So you have Egypt there,
then you have Jordan,
which is teetering.
Then you have Siri venue of Lebanon and his balls on the,
the southern border of Lebanon,
which is constantly,
which you know,
so that's the real thing.
So when people talk about this fantasy of why can't it just look like America,
why can't there just be a democratic one state solution?
First of all,
no one there wants it.
They pull people constantly.
But the second thing is like,
it's not really what that's gonna look like if we dismantle the state of Israel
or is it going to look like enormous bloodshed.
The likes of which we see in a lot of these countries surrounding it.
Like someone once said to me that if you want to know the word for,
you know,
a Jew without a military,
it's the CDS.
Okay.
It's these edis.
It's the people.
It's the minorities in the Middle East who have been absolutely
destroyed and overrun.
And this is like,
it's,
I don't think when Americans talk about this part of the world,
they fully appreciate the sort of absolutely painful and hard decisions and the
grappling with violence really.
You know what happened to Jamal?
Cause Shogi and that Saudi embassy that's like normative for this part of the
world.
So the fact that Israel has somehow with all of its flaws managed to eke out a
western style liberal democracy.
Frankly the only place where you and I would feel happy and comfortable living.
Like why are we never talking about that?
Well I think it's very for people to find the forum,
to discuss it the way you just did and to,
to really lay it out in cold stark reality.
What is the solution?
I mean is this is magic.
The solution right now is to do everything possible to build up the Palestinian
economy too for Israel to build relationships.
Like right now,
it has a very,
very positive relationships with Egypt,
which it gave back the Sinai,
which had had one in the six day,
six day war,
I believe,
gave it back to Egypt for a cold piece,
which it's had.
It has a good relationship of all things.
Who would have thought with Saudi Arabia because of their common enemy you're
on.
I mean,
things shift.
They're rapidly.
Um,
but,
but as for the Palestinians,
the solution is to build up the economy,
make life better,
and support people in movements inside the West Bank that are genuinely
nonviolent.
And those people exist.
It's just frankly,
oftentimes they're murdered by groups like Hamas and their bodies are dragged
through the streets.
If you're accused of being an Israeli collaborator in the West Bank,
you know what happens to you?
You're lynched.
No one talks about that.
No,
no one does talk about that.
Would you be open to discussing this in this sort of a form with that woman from
the women's March?
Uh,
sure.
Do you think she would do something like that?
I don't know.
I'd be open to it.
Do you think that people like her have ever had a conversation with someone like
you who could lay it out?
I know because I think that first of all,
many people who talk about this issue have sort of export aid,
American domestic politics to a foreign region of the world.
Like in a way that this is talked about a lot.
It's like the oppressor,
the oppressed,
the white,
the black.
No,
that's not what's going on.
I don't think people understand when they talk about Israeli Jews that half of
them are Middle Eastern,
like half of Israeli Jews are Arab,
you know,
there's no appreciation of that reality.
They think that Israel was just founded,
you know,
to save the remnant of the Jews who weren't destroyed in the Holocaust.
And yeah,
it helped for those who survived.
But then once the state of Israel was established,
there was a mass exodus of the Jews from all of the Arab countries where they
had been living as second class citizens where they are either self deported
because they were living at as second class citizens or they were expelled.
Again,
that exodus,
that deportation never talked about.
I'd be happy to talk about this with someone from the women's March.
What is the,
what is the response currently like what,
what is the current position that most people are taking about that woman and
about the woman's march in general because of these things,
because of these antiques,
antisemitic statements.
I think a lot of people in the past few weeks,
thanks in part to Meghan Mccain had five minutes on the view with Tamika Mallory
and Bob Land and she did an amazing job grilling them on them.
The view,
the view that it was,
what's changed.
It's amazing.
I know.
But she did an amazing job because,
because frankly because their image was so powerful in the same way that the
image of the Lincoln memorial was so powerful,
journalists just sort of accepted it and didn't interrogate that,
who doesn't want to support that?
But it's our job to be skeptical and criticized.
So I think finally a lot of people woke up to it.
Um,
but again,
I wrote that column in August,
2017 and it took until now everything in that column is the thing people are
talking about.
There was also an amazing 10,000 word expos a and tablet magazine and Jewish
Online magazine that did a lot of that work.
So I think it did reach a tipping point.
The thing that is,
um,
I see a lot of my friends on the left who are Jewish grappling with is that they
so desperately want to be a part of these movements that they're willing to sort
of check their identity at the door in order to gain entry.
And my thing is any progressive movement that's asking you to check your Jewish
identity at the door,
your full Jewish identity,
which is acknowledging that we're not just a faith,
but we're at people.
We're not just people that like have matzah ball soup or something bigger than
that.
That's not a space I want to be a part of.
They would never ask that.
If any other group,
why us?
Why,
why do they ask that?
That that,
that's what the real question.
I really think,
well,
no,
I think a lot of it goes back to what I was saying before,
which is this misunderstanding.
If you see the world in an intersectional way,
okay.
Not As intersectionality was originally meant to be,
but how it functions in the world.
It functions as a caste system and the higher you are on the victim scale,
at least on the left,
and it's reverse on the right,
right on the right,
it's like white cis gendered men are at the top on the left there at the bottom
and the Jews or somewhere close down to there,
at least in the way that the left the left,
I mean this part of the left,
we're talking about the fringe at least for now,
perceive the Jews to be the woke left.
Yeah.
The Jews are not,
the Jews don't rate,
the Jews don't have a place in that victim scale because they've achieved so
much success because they can pass as white because of any number of things.
And so I think that that's a huge reason for it,
which is a huge reason why I think intersectionality is a dead end and why we
need to be talking about ideas and not identity.
Right.
Like that.
That is the thing about America that is so amazing.
And like,
I know it sounds cheesy,
but I really feel it that makes us so special.
We are not a country based on blood and soil.
We are a country whose national common identity is based on ascribing to a
common set of ideas.
That is what we're about.
And so any politics that's insisting from the left or the right that no,
actually what we are is this warring set of groups competing for scarce
resources.
Absolutely not.
To me,
those kinds of politics are unamerican.